welcome to this video playing wgm glee
glue wow I'm Monica such go okay if I'm
pronouncing this halfway correct um yeah
she said she's actually am a grandmaster
not the Goodman Grandmaster owned only
it's got the general GM title I didn't
really know that she played this kind of
stuff okay so we have the two nights two
nights defense she played the wood
steinitz variation here with Knight to
h3 and I went for some line that I had
seen years ago in the games of melon
yolk he played that with f5 and
everything forward kind of ultra
aggressive style on the King side yeah
white has taken a while to relocate her
pieces and in the meantime black
handsome it gained quite some ground in
the center the only bad pieces the night
I'm trying to get it to d6 somewhere
near the near the center Oh a very
difficult position
ok this is a big center ok I'll take
that I will take that there should be
seven yeah editor this this must be ok
for black right I mean this is such a
huge compensation oh poor pieces are
active and I'm trying to play quickly
here not trying to fall back on the on
the clock if she now retreats I'm going
afore now Wow nah don't tell me that
what can survive that that that would be
really really really weird
that a new account actually or this she
has got two thousand five minute games
but would old ones and she hasn't
updated to prove her for ages yeah the
big issue is wide cannot take because I
can even take with the night the pawn
takes us also devastation but night
takes it takes the Queen if she moves
i'm going to win the bishop and Bishop
f5 92 is also losing I think ultimately
now loses a piece and if white cannot
take what are you moving if you move the
night away I'm going three and again I'm
winning this piece yeah that's a
disaster yeah this is this type of game
is that is some why the two nights
defense to the Italian game is really am
somewhat is an attractive opening it
gives you sometimes really really great
attacking games okay I can just take him
I believe the night stays attack the
rookies detect
yeah especially night XD five I was
really surprised about white
that'sthat's really really terrible did
this this is capture I mean I already
thought that this must be quite okay
from here not that's look look at it
briefly yeah this is night h3 was an old
favorite off of Steinitz and later
played by a Fisher even piano I simply
like this position it's a good it's very
active at least and when I was uh yeah I
could have played if already yeah I
wanted to tour for against strong what
was I doing there okay I wanted to
relocate the the night and now night xt5
is really strange I mean really
surprised that the computers actually
that stock fish is actually only giving
black a slight edge here the computer is
basically believing in a way that you
can defend this maybe maybe the column
but but no human player can do that I
can assure you yeah okay here the
cumbersome slowly creeping towards a
winning evaluation or at least a big
edge yes he 3c3 seems to hold on for a
moment but it looks I mean like has got
everything that he wants ever and then
in such an opening Bishop g5 has
something on maybe still be for blasting
through maybe that's too much 94 it's
not that clear yeah a very strong very
strong position okay thanks for watching